all right thanks everyone for coming
you're good thanks everyone for coming
before we begin
[Music]
i pledge um to the land of the united
states of america and to the republic
for which it stands one nation under god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all thank you
[Music]
thank you for attending this community
input session regarding redistricting
please be advised that the session will
be video and audio recorded to be
subsequently placed online and made
publicly available
this is not a typical meeting of the
house or senate committees and will not
be attended by all committee members
this meeting is also going to be
broadcast to local channel 8.
the meeting is occurring in sultan
county at the claremont savings bank
community center
staff general court has worked to secure
places to hold these sessions and i'm
grateful to staff and the organizations
that control the use of the facility for
allowing us to use them
this is a joint meeting of the senate
and house redistricting committee
it's not exactly accurate this is a
meeting of the house redistricting
committee and also the senate
registration committee did you actually
get to see two committees in one
as a result we have members of both the
house and senate here with us tonight
senator gray jewish district center uh
thank you i am senator james gray
i am the chair of the senate select
committee
um
i'll let senator susan introduce himself
in a minute just
uh one thing of note is that the senate
does not allow
thank you i'm senator john soucy i
represent senate district 18 which is
five awards in the city of manchester in
the town of blitzfield i'm a member of
the senate election law committee and
also member of the redistricting special
committee
i'm representative stephen smith deputy
speaker in the hampshire house and
uh vice chair of the house committee on
redistricting and i represent actworth
charlestown ocean
and
thank washington
[Music]
and lucy webber i represent cheshire one
which is
immediately to the south of sullivan
multiple western manchester field and
pinsdale
and i officers serve on the health human
services and elderly affairs committee
in the house
good evening i'm martin smith i
represent durham and strasbourg
[Music]
hi i'm bob nguyen i represent wyndham
in the house of representatives i'm
this
the district committee and also on the
finance committee
good evening my name is wayne mcdonald i
represent
buckingham county district five which is
composed of the town of londonderry
uh in addition to serving on this
committee i am also on the election law
committee in the house and i sat there
with vice chairman
thank you
all right information on the
registration process for the house can
be found on the general court website
once there select house of
representatives then select committees
and stamping committees
you'll find all the committees listed
there including the special committee on
redistricting there's a link there that
you can click that will allow you to
email all the committee members
and a link to the web page where you can
look at previous meeting minutes
documents have been uploaded and
upcoming meeting information
redistricting is a process that appears
throughout the country every 10 years
after the federal census is completed
the population data is used to create
districts for representation at all
levels of government here in new
hampshire our constitution says the
responsibility for the creation of those
districts is that of the legislature
the districts to be redrawn in new
hampshire will be congressional
executive council state senate state
representative county commissioner and
delegates from the state party
convention
there are handouts available that
have more detail on sullivan county
as you get up to speak from the house
representative side it would be helpful
for you to comment on things you might
think are important for redistricting in
sullivan county but of course you can
make comments about the districts as
well
we will be doing this in every county
this is the sign up sheet for anyone
that wishes to speak
and uh so the side note from the
prepared thing what we're really looking
for and why we're going out to all the
counties is
data that's hard to collect
what's working for you with what you
have now what's not working what do you
wish to be left alone or change or it's
impossible to drive from this town to
that town
without locking your hubs in and going
on a crazy dirt road things like that
that's just not information we can get
looking at
so with that
we'll open the
first up representative tanner
good evening
i'm linda tanner i live in summittee and
i'm a state representative for sullivan
district 9. i represent a floaterial
district with a total population of 20
761 voters or citizens
in the 2020 census
if my math is correct this ontario
district represents a 350
deviation from the
3444 voters per representative as
prescribed in the current guidelines
new hampshire as well as sullivan county
has some gerrymandered districts i am
concerned about fair maps
in the
congressional districts executive
council and senate districts
these districts like senate district 9
and executive council district 2 which
come into sullivan county
result in unequal representation and
represent a partisan priority
that needs to be addressed
however tonight
i'm speaking about the sullivan county
house districts
i believe
strongly in fair redistricting maps and
an open and transparent process
i supported an independent redistricting
committee
last term and i do so today
here are the new census figures along
with the current number of
representatives in the eight towns in my
floatarium
cornish has 1 616
citizens uh with three representatives
croydon 801
with two representatives
grantham
3404 with three representatives
newport 6299
with three representatives
plainfield
2459 with three representatives
springfield one thousand two hundred and
fifty nine
with three representatives
son of the three thousand three hundred
and forty two with two representatives
and unity
with three representatives and i'm a
representative in each one of those
districts
the goal of fair redistricting should be
equal population among the various
districts so that the vote of each
citizen
for representation in the new hampshire
house is approximately equal
to that of any other citizen with a
slight five percent deviation
ontario districts are complicated and
confusing
they consist of many towns
eight towns in my case
with vastly different populations
connections and economies
the fact that a town or two towns have
one representative from their area as
well as one floating over them
gives the impression that they have two
or three representatives in the house
and that is misleading
it treats these towns as if they had a
two or three member district which they
do not
moterial districts pose several
disadvantages to voters as well
the average citizen doesn't know what a
plutarial district is take it from me
had that question many times
what it accomplishes or why it exists
voters are less likely to know their
district representative because the
proterial district covers such a large
area
the proterial district representatives
are not part of the everyday
interactions and connections in the
individual communities
for example
two ends of my district plainfield
is much different from the other end
unity
plainfield has a population of 2459
and is truly a part of the upper dollar
with ties and connections in the upper
part of sultan county
while unity population 1581
has very strong connections with
claremont
when voting on an issue that arises in
the house
with eight towns it's very difficult to
represent all their local government
schools and economies fairly
in the 2002
court case berlin versus chandler the
court rejected clotarial districts as an
unsound redistricting device
we are a representative democracy
whenever possible districting should
produce one person for one vote
districts should be drawn so that every
voter has the same equal representation
as every other voter
this is accomplished by creating as many
single districts as possible
i urge you to consider single districts
in grantham
population 3404
in sunapee
for a single representative district
in newport with 6299
for a two-person representative district
further i would urge the committee to
set multi-district towns multi-towns and
districts with a priority to their
economic and governmental connections
and please eliminate the plotarios
thank you
representative
[Music]
gotling currently representing sullivan
county district 2 which is comprised of
the towns of santa fe and croydon and i
am also a member of the santa fe board
of selection
i am speaking here tonight as a
long-time president
to suggest the redistricting committee
follow the new hampshire constitution
and restore son of youth status as a
single district
based on the 2000 census sanofi became a
single district a status that many of
the town's citizens had worked hard to
achieve
and valued highly
however during the 2010
redistricting process sanofi lost its
standing as a single district even
though its population was about as close
as it could get to the perfect number
sonically found itself alive with a town
with whom it shared virtually no common
interest
and as well it was enrolled in the
eighth birthday town ontario district
you just heard uh described by
representatives
it felt like a gerrymandered decision
hoping to tilt the political winds
and the ballot results in a certain
direction
it did not feel as if the constitutional
requirement
was being followed
as of now sonoff is again easily within
the five percent standard
are the town citizens once again
going to feel as if that constitutional
is always dangling just out of reach
and i would say the same is true for uh
newport because they've had the same
experience
if in your wisdom the interim maps or
map that you design keeps the centipede
connected to one two or even eight towns
would you try to give us a partner with
whom we share common interests and i
would suggest that the town of
springfield would be
useful we have a contractual agreement
to use the transfer station
and because the towns also share a
watershed many citizens participate
enjoying efforts to maintain the
national resources of our area
so good luck on your job and i hope you
make us all very happy
thank you we will do our best
representative sullivan
thank you
thank you all for traveling uh
my name is brian sullivan representative
uh from sullivan district one
representing cornish plainfield grantham
and uh springfield
and uh first of all i'd like to say a
little to everything rep tanner had to
say
um i think this materials are very
confusing
very good people in the four towns i
represent actually know that they have
three representatives um
who represent them um
they know generally about the oxfam um
playing field and myself but not so much
about uh representative tanner because
she's spread the event
um i would also say that when it comes
to getting out and meeting people
it's far easier for
someone with one or two towns to get out
and meet the voters which is what
nature's all about um than someone with
eight towns um so um i would strongly
encourage you to uh give bill say
another thought um
speaking more specifically about uh
sullivan district one um
uh
mr chairman you uh referenced um
uh four-wheel drive tracks um
we've got one um
[Music]
playing field uh i thoroughly enjoyed
providing the back roads those two towns
um
um with their lovely places
but they are very separated from
springfield
[Music]
and literally um i used to um
periodically have somebody stopping when
i was out in the neighborhood
with an old farms and people would uh
pull over and say um
can you tell me how to get to ko now koa
and their gps sent them into my
neighborhood thinking they were going to
take the croydon turnpike
turnpike many times you can't really get
through with a
four-wheel drive unless you're going to
do some serious damage
so
there's a lot of ways to
cut up this pie um i would suggest that
uh it would make sense to have two
districts um
one of them being
cornish another one being uh grantham
and springfield um if you want to
representative godwin's dreams come true
uh grantham and um
could be
a
district perhaps
um but uh
they do need to be joining each other um
grantham and plainfield are um
when you look at the map the big black
blob at the top looks like it's very
much a drain
but
[Music]
one of the things that is joining it is
a big game
um which
gets fenced in you don't go there i
don't go there um
but yeah but basically it's that game
preserve that really gives us a lot of
our common uh geographical territory
nobody holds that
so
those are my thoughts again thank you
for coming and
i wish you luck as well
thank you
representatives
all right um
[Music]
i've worked with low-income families
individuals in southern counties
for over 30 years
i'm also a new board member i am
speaking on the behalf
of the granite state debate action fund
which is a statewide debate organization
dedicating to increasing voter crown and
lacking fairness
and people of color communities
i trust and hope that you're here today
and we've been traveling around the
state
to listen and act upon our concerns
and that this is just not
um
it's important that you ensure
that this redistricting process is
transparent
inclusive and fair
so that you get your residents like
myself to not get even
this university whether or not you join
together
we just usually have college interests
questions to ask to the rest of the
southern primary world
and transportation systems
i've lived in southern county since 1981
turned from parker's age
i thought about
living in the hampshire kind of changed
over time
when i first came here as a 25 year old
i was kind of annoying when people
called me exactly
over time
i became
what people call me garbage
to
is
um
that it sounds like fear
but it sounds like
it's personally impossible and i think
it was
let's explain
she had representing people the
different stuff
somebody
that allows
those people to share some kind of
interests i also
understood for the first time today
about this idea i've always wondered why
she's one of my reps now i understand
why i
never made any sense
and i actually
would be better served
by not having
multiple reps in these small towns but
instead having one round that represents
times it's
all right the last thing i want to talk
about is the capital council
municipalities and several countries
[Music]
this is a clear example
unfortunately of excessive partisanship
and we just
american district 2
allowed
republican aggregate manufacturers and
voters into one district
other districts
this is classic charity
since councilman martinson
your concerns
to complete your job
you'll need to return to self-accounting
after the proposed new maps have been
created
through transparency and verification
process requires
the public to have the opportunity to be
here
and confidence on the opponent's maps
before we decision is fine
thank you
might interest you to know the
representatives that have known me for
years but from other parts of the state
always ask me so what's it like up in
the north country like dude i have no
idea an hour from massachusetts
all right representative clutier
thank you mr chairman members committee
i think maybe i'm going to take my mask
off to make sure that it's picked up
properly i think i'm far enough away
okay again i'm representing john clutier
from sullivan county district 10. i sort
of have to represent the entire city of
claremont
and i first want to say although i'm
most interested in
the house districts i also want to take
time to urge the committee to do a fair
and impartial redistricting job for our
state senate districts our executive
council districts our county
commissioner districts as well as our
u.s congressional districts
these are just as important
uh to a lot of people
uh so that's i i know you have a very
difficult job
with all due respect to a previous
committee some of the districts and not
so much the rep some of the executive
councils state senators
they were a little bit strange to make
uh put it that way that's my opinion
but i do want to speak also about the
house redistricting
and i've been around a while i've
actually been involved in two
redistricting efforts
and uh the first one and i by the way
when i first selected i represent just
one
2000 census we had a
redistricting battle between the
democratic governor republican
legislature and in the end there was an
impasse and a judicial master from south
carolina i believe had to draw the
legislative district we didn't complete
it until the end of july 2002
we had to push off the filing date for
the primary and i remember that very
well we had it was a very hectic time
and we
what ended up it may have been a fair
process and maybe every most everybody
in the state was satisfied but in my
case i went from representing one
district award in claremont to
representing the not
[Applause]
[Music]
only one available
in 10 years we had that district from
2002 to 2012 that we elected a candidate
from outside claremont the claremont
candidates whether they were democrats
or republicans always got away
when i went to those i did the best you
know of course i'm from a city and i'm a
city guy and so it took me a while to
you know town government was a good
experience i went to some of the town
meetings with both communities school
meetings got to know some of the people
and that was one of their complaints
constantly
you know they we don't like this system
with all their respect for you
representing we know you're your
representative but we think we ought to
have some more equity in us
and all you know not just have claire
monitors dominate us in the new
hampshire house of representatives at
least we ought to have a say so i think
we ought to i urge this committee to try
to create as smaller districts as
possible and give some of our smaller
communities a voice in the new hampshire
house and i think somebody my colleagues
mentioned some examples
and i realized that it's partly based on
population
but i feel that it needs to be fair
if we can pile up and get four seats
again that's fine
uh but i think that i'm also concerned
as chair of the sullivan county
delegation about these other small
communities in sullivan county as well
they've combined some of them
if you have to combine some of them
based on the census you ought to look
for areas of common
concern for example and claremont's a
good by itself i think another one a
good case to be made is made for one rep
is is cornish and playing field they
have their own sau now so maybe they'll
at least at least get a rep because
there's a lot of history between those
two communities
and maybe webster and goshen for example
another history i used to play with
joint school district i'm just giving
you some examples i don't mean to
dictate but i think you ought to look
for that what some of these community
towns have in common some towns don't
have as much in common
so i urge this uh committee to do that
uh and i'm hoping we're gonna be able to
keep our 13th seat sullivan county we're
one of the smallest counties in the
state
and i hope we'll keep at least 13 and i
would like to keep
support requirement but i know it will
not be easy and you have a very tough
job i'm sort of glad i'm not in your
shoes to be friendly so
i would but i said i welcome to solve
con i'm glad you're coming and getting
input and if you can come afford to come
back that's fine but i will be anxious
to see what happens with this committee
and what you recommend
uh come whenever we take it up probably
sometime in may
or june thanks very much appreciate your
work
alice robinson
good evening and welcome to sullivan
county thank you for coming
all this way and
great to see you and have you here
i
uh don't do that
i also want to give you each a special
thank you
for the amount of time and energy that
you're putting into this campaign
you know you can't possibly
satisfy everybody and
hey all the big money you're getting
paid to do this and all of that is uh we
really appreciate all the work you're
doing um to put together a groundwork
for new hampshire elections for the next
10 years
and thanks
i have four points i wanted to mention
to you so i'll make this quick
first is
as you consider sullivan county's
community of interests communities of
interest
please keep in mind that ours very much
follow the major transportation routes
for example
i-91 and route 12a
come down the connecticut river
that makes it very easy for those towns
that are in the western part of the
county to keep in touch plainfield all
the way down to langton
and that's where they shop and that's
where they travel and that's how they
get out of the region and all those
things
at the same time there's only one
continuous east-west route in the county
and that's state route 11 that stretches
from sunapee to newport to claremont
so in order for anybody to get across as
brian was telling you
um
you have to get
to that route the third thing is that
grantham has easy access to 89
and we orient along that major route
um
there aren't any other towns really that
have an exit to 89 so if anyone wants to
go there they have to come to us
but there also are
real challenges for those towns that are
not on one of those major routes
because
they have to
connect
with we'll call them border
towns and some of them
some of those border towns actually are
out of the county
there's been a conversation so far and
uh as brent as i think the only
representative of bransons who's here
i
i agree that uh springfield has much
more alliance
with sunapee than it does with grantham
grantham is 40 people short
of that magic number to get our own
representative
and i would like to suggest that we
actually um
undoubtedly
got at least that many people
just in this summer when people were
moving up here so
we deserved that extra one and if you
want to give us croydon two we'll take
point um mccartney
they can't get anywhere without coming
through grantham um unless they're going
west so uh
those are some things to think about
the other thing i'd like to suggest is
that you remember that sullivan is a
purple county
the checklist on file with the secretary
of state
reflecting voter registration as of the
2020 general election
show a near tie between democrats and
republicans
9 676 democrats versus 9 415 republicans
with about 1300 13 000 undeclared
please make sure that voting districts
reflect this balance
in the same way new hampshire is also a
purple state
as you amend districts for the executive
council particularly
u.s house of representatives and the
state senate
please pay attention to this balance and
make districts as competitive as
possible
finally i want to thank you again for
holding these very valuable county
meetings
once you establish draft maps that
you're comfortable with i hope you will
hold one more series of meetings for
each county's residents to comment on
your work
last spring governor sununu told nhpr's
larry
laura kenoi
on nh on nhpr if any of the district
redistricted maps are gerrymandered
i will veto them
only with balanced non-partisan
districts established with a transparent
public process can we be assured that
our state government will fairly fairly
represent all new hampshire residents
thank you for your attention and if you
have any questions or clarifications i'm
happy that and i have a few copies of
this so you could have it for your files
thank you
so much
it's great we love having it
can i get your autograph
hmm
[Music]
my name is kyle messier i'm uh simply a
resident of sherman nature i'm here to
echo whatever whatever saying much
detail that i hope that we realize we
are a perfect state and that feldman
county is a purple county and that we
redistrict in a way that is um not
partisan and
will reflect on the communities
that we redistrict in a way that
communities that are like-minded can be
worked together because of our economies
our
travels our education systems and that i
hope when you do
thank
you all right anyone else
[Music]
thank you all for coming and with that
we'll close the
house session
thank you everyone
[Music]